this is how it's done man this is the
part they don't see
[Music]
[Music]
guy already hey y'all alright so here we
go this is this is gonna be so good I'm
so excited welcome back hot breath verse
hot breath we have we have a raw comedy
talk today I'm in Chattanooga right now
working with mr. Showtime for the second
time we went out did our little ritual
where the headliner takes the feature
out last time we work together and this
guy was full of so much information
about comedy I knew he would be the
perfect mentor for the hot breath verse
he asked me to come back work with him
again luckily I don't know why but we're
glad and we're all better for it so
prepare yourselves for a raw comedy talk
with Eric as well eric lonas yes
pipe down sit he was hosting last time
we're here in Chattanooga he wanted to
come out here and learn from history
show time as well so prepare to take
notes just learn this is the side of
comedy most people don't get to hear and
see so that being said gentlemen welcome
to the hot breath of ours so I'm so
excited to actually record our talk this
time because last time we talked he took
notes I was taking know taking note you
were so generous not only information
but you should like Booker information
and just so many tips and after last
night I'm glad we're doing this cuz like
it's it's funny and doing the show I've
interviewed people 20 years in who are
even saying I'm just now figuring this
out but as we start in comedy we're like
I'm nine years in and I'm like oh and
nine years are gonna be bulletproof and
then last night I had two great shows
Friday night and then Saturday both
shows were just like pulling teeth and I
was like which is unusual uses the other
way around
oh did the Friday's or the rough
Roddy's usually played a little bit
harder a little bit tougher yeah
especially late show Fridays but yeah I
I blame your shoes yeah people rose like
my shoes yeah your shoes yeah yeah I
don't know what it is but yeah you uh
I'm trying to think I told you last
night after the show I have more respect
for you after the show you did because
you stuck with it you didn't you didn't
fail you didn't change a single line you
said this is my material no I'm gonna do
it and I'm not going to change who I am
I had a lot of respect for that because
a lot of comics when they are on stage
and they are bombing or they are getting
nothing in response to just silence bill
start doing crowd work there stop
dropping f-bombs right let's talk maybe
turning on the audience
uh-huh you were like I'm just gonna do
my jokes I'm just gonna do the jokes and
and you stuck with it and that to me is
a sign of a plug that's what a real pro
does okay a real throw goes I'm doing my
show which means to me that you are a
true comedian or drink me because the
ones who are not true comedians in my
opinions it's just my opinion I probably
get some hey Thomas are the ones that
all of a sudden they're bombing and they
just change your they are their go I'm
just I'm just gonna throw everything out
the window I'm gonna change who I am I
go that's not that if that's who you are
that means you're changing for every
audience right and you want the audience
to change for you you want to manipulate
the audience into your way of thinking
or not not the other way around
okay so great I mean it was just one
shot was [ __ ] was Bo yeah show oh
yeah it at the show after the Late Show
Friday Saturday we you you walked
offstage and you're a tall guy you're
like 17
yeah you and Manu bull can look eye to
eye and you walk back and you took your
t-shirt that you sell and you just threw
it and no Bridget's on stage giving the
introduction yeah you know and you just
take me show you guys so we were to go I
hate comedy I did I said I'm quitting
gone I'm quitting and and I looked at
her I said it's not that bad
hoping that you would believe me no but
it was it wasn't you that was bad it I
mean you did the exact same jokes on
Friday and Thursday
and killed you killing Thursday you
killed Friday kill Friday bull shows and
the Friday Late Show was not an easy
crowd and you killed Thursday you killed
both Shores Friday you didn't change a
single joke between Friday and Saturday
and yet the crowd and I think I told you
of the reason why I thought the crowd
has sort of turned on you mm-hmm and not
turn on you didn't didn't buy into you
was because um I felt like what you were
talking about on stage felt like you
were condescending to the crowd because
I think it hit too close to home
uh-huh which is not a bad thing you just
have to learn when you walk on stage and
this this is what every comet needs to
learn is that you just don't walk on
stage before I've been doing this for 26
years
and you don't know do my world record
even though mom's doing clean ship
season do corporate shows whatever I
walk the room I looked through the room
I look again the rafters I quickly when
I look at a crowd or I god I'm listening
to them talking before the show I'm
listening to see what kind of group they
are and I don't think enough comics are
doing a pre-show
research you know you've got to know
your class you have to know your
audience and I think if you had done a
little bit more of that you would have
started your show with less of the
accent some Ville math stuff it started
more with your wife stuff because all
your wife stuff and about being married
and outsourcing all that stuff that
killed that was work and so you start
talking about you know I'm from what
chrome right you know yeah they were
like wait a second that's how I talk now
are you making fun of me and that's how
you start up the show and I think that's
why they turn today they were like I
think hit too close to home
oh oh so it's almost had to get them on
my side before I couldn't hate them
they're always have to get them on your
side first
okay I mean you see my show now what 12
times yeah it's encryption I look
different I dressed different my show is
more of a Broadway show than a stand-up
show and I gotta get them on I gotta get
every artists on my side within the
first 45 seconds because they don't buy
into what mr. Showtime is on stage
they're not gonna buy in debt anything
and I'm on say for everyone power in
some cases an hour and 20 minutes
depending a warmth on TV and if they
don't buy in the first 45 seconds that's
a long hour 20 and so if you see the way
of my show ultra much like a rock
concert like the like I love bands like
kiss and the police and they way they
open their shows with something big
their first song is a hit first song is
a well-known hit so I go onstage as if
it's a rock concert so people like okay
like what are we seeing it's like gab be
grabby I grabbed that first joke I do is
always something local
it's always something local I'm not
making fun of their town I'm actually
making fun of myself for never
understand the local you know right
habit right right right I think I'm
poking fun myself but the crowd goes hey
he knows your town got him got him your
mind
mm-hmm they're my crowd and I do
whatever I want win it for that I can
shove marshmallows my mouth and put a
straitjacket on I can dance around in
spandex like trim package trip all that
I can do whatever I want
what is like the worst like show you've
had cuz that imagine with all these
moving parts you've probably had some
where there's technical difficulties are
wardrobe malfunction or something like
what are well what was it it was uh it
wasn't the worst show but was it what
was it a Friday was a first show Friday
the lights just went out doing myself
did my show oh my gosh yeah I think
you're outside smoking and doing men
[Laughter]
thank you very much thank you
yeah not gonna be great yeah we have to
Songkran yeah we are yeah where to place
called ribbon loin I know when you learn
Atlanta you don't get anything close to
barbecue so if they have to ask if
you're famous I guess you're not I have
to go I was that crappy night I went out
to lunch from a Dave Carroll he's a
newscaster here in Chattanooga and we
got to lunch went to the Cracker Barrel
and we've both got recognized at karate
recognized at Cracker Barrel and the
lady who recognized us the two ladies
they want to take the picture with me
not with Dave and I thought really we
want to take you for your Dave goes I'm
Andrew oh no not you so yes today way so
technical difficulty the worst like a
bomb cuz you know I get caught white
here how about getting food or like epic
bombs like 26 years you had to have some
that you just unforgettable well yeah
we've we've all had bad jokes right and
when you're a young comic you have you
remember the bad shows but after 26
years I try to go back what was the last
truly bad show I had and I don't know
Yap - I actually have to go back a long
time
and I think it was actually here in
Chattanooga and the old flow the old
comedy catch they moved it and it was a
Late Show Friday and for what reason the
crowd just a teeny just hating it I mean
it was pure silence for an hour and I
couldn't figure out why I also could not
figure out why and I walked as a Jim
Michael the owner comes up he goes well
they hated you and I and I go I go I
don't know what and he goes I don't know
why you look I have no idea why this
crowd just because I don't know why
they're here
I know maybe thought it was in Al Anon
convention know nothing maybe maybe I
thought this is a drug awareness or
dislike you know they were came to see
Jesus I don't know what they were
expecting but baby if we weren't here
for comedy if you do in your
straightjacket material and I well know
this but this just about 12 years ago my
first book volunteer and I wasn't doing
I was the midnight swinger back then the
midnight slammer that was my original
character oh my yeah and they just hated
me and and I thought for sure Michael
was never got a book me again
I was like you know he's never gonna
book me again but the thing the thing
that club owners know is that one bad
show does not you know make your career
thank good and now and now he were and
now to go to call me catch a website
Michael actually has manager guaranteed
next to my name is all that yeah like if
you do not have a good time at Mike Hill
he will give you money back and out of
all the comics he's ever booked in
almost 30 years I'm the only one who's
ever done that yeah so whoo Midnight's
where was like just like material no
municipal I've always been a character
comedian a characters me always I've
never been one for unemployed and I okay
always been a character I've always
believed that character comedy
character-driven comedy was more my
forte you know like like Steve Martin
was a character the wild crazy guy
Groucho Marx Charlie Chaplin ease our
characters and I would agree that my
strength was portraying a character I'm
a big fan of kiss
I've always enjoyed kissing the way they
put on a joke with these characters that
the star man space man demon captain and
they embodied his characters on the
stage well I can't I didn't come up with
a name I'm Fred Kirk Nolan who was my
mentor came up with the name midnight
swinger we developed this really crazy
Vegas kind of guy and we built this show
around between nights when the character
and I did for 15 years I took it as far
as I could go and about five years ago
it was my 20s at times now about five
years ago I took as far as I could go I
realized I got I gotta make a change so
I called the Balmer I called him some
really close friends and I said listen
I'm gonna completely destroy my show I'm
gonna break it down to nothing like him
get rid of everything break it down to
its basic how would you describe me in
Hannah to words how would you describe
me David Scott and 180 words and they
all came back with either some variation
of Showtime showman you know it's the
show and it was always show shoulders in
the knee so I started thinking and
thinking and thinking and thinking
so we're online sought searching
Showtime mr. Showtime I am mr. Showtime
it turns out no one owns I am mr.
Showtime no one owns the website no one
owns the Twitter's new and constant
Instagram with a Facebook so I got it
got the I got the website I am it
Icom started doing all this mr. show
time and the show just completely blew
up again it's text wrought up against I
getting you know more and more bookings
because people realize when you see mr.
Showtime on the Malky and stopping and
you do you feel like most comedians are
a character even if it's a character
themselves in a city like it's funny you
mentioned you've made a shift in your
show because I'm doing that and I'm
trying to get more autobiographical and
more talking about me and my origin
story and trying to create material that
really only I could say yeah like I
could watch a vlog and - important ok
doing material that is unique to you is
the most important thing in comedy
mm-hmm because the worst even the worst
thing you wanna be is generic the once
you want deal Greta bankin the worst
thing you can make if you want to do is
though if Joel Meyers gets sick we can
replace in the discount right and no one
would make a difference right that's the
worst thing you want to happen to you
you've got to be unique you've got to be
who you are
your material has got to be unique to
you no one else can do your stuff so
what's the sense I get from you and I I
think I may mention the first time I saw
you is that you have this storyteller
approach to comedy you are telling
stories about
life being where you're from your wife
you know what well you know I have kids
are not your time a story okay I can't
tell you jokes I can I couldn't tell
jokes about having an Asian life I don't
have an agent wife right those are yours
mm-hmm so what you need to do in my
opinion is expand on that and get rid of
the generic you know axes nd you know we
don't sound like that
no type of you know the kind of stuff
that you're doing like the Shawn role
you know that is literally where I'm
from I understand that yeah but it's not
unique to you I'm saying
Wow not unique to you everybody what you
need to do that is what set you apart
that's gold
every comedian is to remember that yeah
I mean you look at the great comedians
they do stuff that if you hear someone
do maybe this was I don't know how older
younger listeners are or your watchers
are but there was a time when Eddie
Murphy was the greatest stand-up comic
in the world in the world and he did a
bit about wanting to get the ice cream
truck yeah all right
anybody else that tried to do that joke
or that bit it was Eddie Murphy it was
unique to him was the situation unique
no was the way he did it unique yes
that's what made it that's what made him
great that'll make him legend sir you've
got to do if you're gonna do something
that is going to be general you better
make it unique to you I mean I talk
about when I'm on stage I don't just
fall down I mean so about that I do
jokes you know about the station wagon
or long dogs or you know I do a bit
about McGruff the Crime Dog I'm not the
only one does joke behind McGruff the
Crime Dog the way I do it if someone
tries to do it like me they'll go
that's mr. Sholto that's what you need
to work on as we need to focus on
material that's you need to use okay
that's been my big shift is like as I'm
approaching ten years in this it's like
all right I you know I want to be saying
something I want people to be learning
about me because yeah and since I've
started to make that shift
now I'm getting people coming up after
the show like not saying you're funny
but like that's funny like they're like
oh the thing you said about kids is just
like yeah like I'm starting to get those
reactions yeah yeah well you know you're
on the right track i yeah I think I ice
list you before it I think you need be
focusing a lot more on the trophy
husband line though cuz I think that is
unique and I think you can actually have
that as a jumping-off point of almost
every bit you do but
got it hit it I don't know if you
believe it I mean you're on stage I
don't know if you actually believe it
sometimes you see a comic on stage tell
a joke
and you know they don't believe in the
joke you know it we said yeah he's
telling a joke but the audience isn't
laughing because audience will know a
fake - we'll know a fake quick and
they'll go yeah I don't believe him at
all and I think that goes with it when
when you're selling it you sell a ton of
t-shirts after the show I've seen you
sell but a bunch of t-shirts cuz he's
like oh yeah mmhmm yeah because when you
will buy their shirts for their
husband's men will buy because I think
it's plenty for themselves yeah you know
but if you were to make that the
centerpiece of your show and then build
off of that you can go all over the
place because they'll know you as the
trophy husband and that is an amazing
kind of corny who cares
your ideas to be remember right you want
people to go who is that guy we saw who
did the trophy husband bit didn't want
to go who's the guy who was wearing the
Dockers and the shirt what was they
don't care about that maybe they will
remember that they'll remember something
I did
so as comedians thinking about like how
you asked your comedian friends if you
could sum me up and like a wart like a
couple words it's almost comedians
taking the time to ask friends or look
at themselves right I were to sum myself
up and a couple works right yeah it's
hard to see the board for the trees when
you're when you're talking about
yourself I'll try to be honest with
yourself it's really hard if we don't
see what other people are seeing right
so you have to have outside people who
trust people yet you
no oven have yer your best interest at
heart she's all confused likewise our
camera know what we're gonna do is look
I do a slip and fall so some people that
you trust you like you know that can
have the best interest at all because
let's be honest a lot of comics are
trying to sabotage other comics I don't
care what they say about this industry
this is a very backstabbing industry and
so you've got to know who your true
friends are
mmm so when you ask YouTube friends
described role buyers how would they
describe you you know and then take that
to heart and listen to what they're
saying and then go okay what am I doing
wrong you know because I love this stuff
about when you go to Merlot college you
do 60 it was 60% to 40% men then you
found out that system said I'm the women
wanted 60% of the women right that's a
great line that's a really smart line I
love that stuff that stuff is so much
funnier than the you know the whole you
know
you know reforms southerner you know
Amma
you know I'm a recycled you know white
trash yeah you know and all that is like
somewhat newer and me being a little
more cuz eat literally like it took me a
while to even just say like I'm from a
trailer it just hurts to say that yeah
but but the way you say it is fine you
say if I could air B&B
and what is an uber uber siren game it's
a great line so I'm just like exploring
my origin story and where I'm from
why it sounds like that's just a shade
of it or something like the honky tonky
stuff right isn't well it's kind of
again I think that material hurt you
last night because the one about African
Americans in the room last night it was
all over the oh when I tried to go out I
was grabbing for strong yeah I know I
could that whole show I'm shot like yeah
next time yeah I was in an inner panic
like yeah it the two shows last night
we're honestly the most uncommon on
stage in a long time what both of them
to your credit he didn't look at it I
will deliver it it will employ at least
won't you get a look at and that's what
impressed me I knew you a panic because
when when I'm gonna run a comic abrasive
years is a younger comic onstage just
really struggling we see your eyes and
you guys because I know you know mine
you're going to the rolodex of jokes in
your head and mine and you're like
you're actually talking you're talking
but you're having an out-of-body
experience you're talking and like you
what what was like a 30 minute or what
was a five-minute bit all of a sudden
becomes 30 seconds yeah you're like oh
oh under the next on the next like I
pulled out something like from way deep
I hadn't said in like several years on
the second show I was so desperate like
I pulled out
old sexting joke I hadn't said in
literally probably like six years right
it just like popped out of like
desperation right I was like I don't
even want to say this but I am grasping
for straws right now that's why and you
older on this as you just get get in
deep in business you always have a joke
in reserve things are going bad
naturally said joke oh this is my I'm
telling this joke I'm gonna reset the
narrative I'm gonna get them all back it
doesn't matter what the joke is it could
really just be a joke joke something
that resets the crowd like you know it
kills it's there's no way it's not gonna
work and that's your reset show and you
don't do it in your show you that is
that is break glass in case of emergency
[Laughter]
always have a reset timer research and
and to joke that you cannot have in your
show because if you're bombing and your
tour you reset joke in there in the
midst of bombing it's gonna bomb also
you got to stop take a breath take a
drink and then hit your reset joke and
then start again it's almost like saying
I'm gonna sit for 30 minutes the first
time is sucks okay reset let's start
this over with this 20 minute scent okay
I always forget the trouble I've had
that happen I mean we've all had rough
shows where we have to do a reset I
Drive a reset job and I and I don't do
it unless and I haven't done it this we
haven't done in a while but there's a
joke that I have that if I leave it he
said it's in my back pocket and it kills
it just kills and once you aren't is
laughing they forget audiences are so
forgiving if you try to be funny
if you're bombing for ten minutes and
then you reset and then the cross-ice
like it they will forget about the ten
minutes you know I was gonna be about
the ten minutes the club owners gonna
forget one to ten minutes they want to
see what's the crowd like we need a walk
offstage what you know if you walk up
taste two thunders what lap Late Show
last night and I even told this that was
not an easy crowd Late Show last night
was not easy crowd even I was my goal
last night was to just talk louder than
them because they were they weren't they
weren't heckling and they were talking
about my show to each other they were
just so loud so I had to keep on
struggling and fighting to keep their
attention yeah and when I was done the
crowds on the feet they're laughing you
forget about the struggle that dealt
will cuz I did I was doing a joke all
week about the highway here we have to
come to a complete stop before you can
merge onto the highway
that trucks been killing all week black
Late Show last night late oh sorry night
silence and I'm like you know Oh bill
you know so and I knew okay they don't
laugh at that okay that's weird I did
the joke bottom you know the local
meteorologists started getting it back
on my side starting to joke about being
you know finding out that I'm officially
a middle-aged they started coming back
to me and I did and I knew where I was
gonna get him I knew who hasn't Gillis
who's I talk about talking about a
Smokey the Bear and McGruff the Crime
Dog
and corduroy pants and then the crowd
that I had them then I had him and I
lost him again because the chest got
dropped the checks got dropped and the
crowd goes uh-huh oh my god we're
alcoholics that is funny you mentioned
then the audience being forgiving and I
think comedians get stuck in our head on
likewise if one joke misses then we
start to shrink onstage now don't miss
it's like a shrink but it's like like
you and your there's one the best
comments I've had when you had told me
after the first show it's like you kept
fighting and you kept fighting what I
noticed I did a lot some jokes it really
hard and then the jokes they weren't
connecting to who didn't hit it all
right they were still forgiving me and
giving me that next chance but maybe
it's important for comics just remember
just because this joke doesn't work it
doesn't mean the next one wrong I
honestly believe in my heart that the
audience is there because they want to
laugh they're not there to cry they're
not there to be angry they're there
because they wonder laughs whatever
reason they love comedy they had a bad
day they got their tickets whatever
they're there because they want to laugh
and if you have a bad joke they're like
okay we're gonna have a good time he's
gonna get the next one okay the crowd
wants the crowd wants you to see scene
there's no doubt in my mind the crowd
wants to see every comic kill they want
to laugh for 90 minutes and I think that
is very important to remember when
you're on stage that if you're bombing
don't turn on the crowd the crowd is
there because they want you to just
succeed because they want to have fun
they're paying money I pained buying
drinks they wanna have fun it's like
going to a movie in the movie sucks you
walk out disappointed I think no one
goes to a vendors end game okay
right right right they go because I hope
this is a good movie
I wouldn't saw yesterday I really want
to be a good movie it wasn't the reviews
lied to me it was cute it wasn't a tour
de force but I want to be great you know
it wasn't I walked out disappointed
going back firing on scene something
else I didn't waste my money hoping to
have a bad time you come to compliment
wanted a good time so if you have a bad
joke the joke doesn't work on you don't
don't
it's like a really a friend of mine told
me it's like being a relief pitcher in
baseball if you have a bad game and you
blow us save you're gonna be called on
the next day to come out again you don't
think about what the save you blew the
day before go out there yeah you clean
the slate you clean the slate and then
you go out and do it again is the is the
Booker the the club owner for this
instance like that was another part of
like I see him in the back watching I'm
like that's just one more layer of
stress I'm adding to myself in the show
like how like I mean how serious that
did that is a legitimate issues little
note it's a legitimate concern right
when it comes to the crowd or the owner
you know Michael is known for I know 12
13 years I've never seen lack of one of
my shows ever because he just Sita sits
back there and watches he observes
you know Michael is not a comedian but
he knows comedy it's like Simon Cowell
said I'm not a singer but I know when I
hear a good singer okay Michael
that can't do jokes can't be calm me but
he knows what good comedy is so is he
watching me like well he's still
fighting or is he like oh yeah her
letting my show no no you're not
he's not thinking you're ruining the
show not at all okay because Michael
knows about elves but sometimes and this
is gonna be kind of crazy say because
you never hear this very often
sometimes crap just solved hmm
and everybody says never never blame the
crowd never blame the crowd huh and for
the most part though right
you never blame the crowd I never blame
the crowd for a bad show but sometimes
crowds just suck I'm blaming them no
they just suck and you had a missed an
issue Late Show Saturday more Late Show
sat in an early show Saturday I thought
Early Show sadi weren't as bad as you
thought you were I think if you had
recorded you would realize I the quarter
part of your set accidentally and you
were now as bad as you thought you on
first show Saturday Late Show Saturday
things got off the rails when you did a
joke
the two most popular languages are
Spanish and Chinese and you go who here
speaks Spanish and some I'm not going to
say who goes no and you're like it's
like going okay we know you CLE want to
build a wall no this is America yeah but
I just kept going yeah but that was your
home yeah and then you go no this is
America and I just kept moving past it
but I could do just like look you know
gosh yeah look I have six tags in this I
can't do any more because nobody here
well again and then you pull the chute
on that joke and then that's where like
know your audience no thing but yeah guy
said that are you thinking okay this is
a build a wall crowd and
and I never talk politics on stage I
never talk politics is Dave off stage I
am very political I am very opinionated
and I believe the way our country is
going is the wrong direction but you
have a crowd here in Chattanooga
you know excellence the 99% build a wall
and supporters so you should know that
going in before you joke like that yeah
and I did I had this whole act out with
book titles I shouldn't have done either
like I love you've been doing that all
it's been dying it just does a crescendo
like well that what the problem is it
ain't big dying oh wait I don't think
people know their book titles I tried to
point you when I said these are book
titles when you go here at Sweet Valley
High I'm going
no one knows that's a series of books I
know it's sad that I know him because of
her girls but I hide the last week pally
hi you do that on Thursday it went okay
you did first off Friday it went okay
and then it just went down and it'll
Mike come on about you but I respect you
because I go on I am doing this bit I am
having this bit though okay because the
whole bit is almost for the one life
and this kills at the library that line
cracks me up I just I cannot I can't
wait you to do the [ __ ] it's like here
you go
you see I like doing that bit because
it's an exercise I want to get more
animate on stage this is why I like
watching you and you almost like
provoking laughs off of gestures or
you're provoking response on your
physicality I want I want to get more
like multi-dimensional in my show like
that
wish me why and that's good exercise
that is why when you get a concussion
bit about being tackled yeah that bit is
something you should you should be that
should be one of the first five-minute
jokes in your five minutes which are
within five minutes you should be doing
that joke okay because you should you
should be frog if you want to be
biographical you're gonna be a
storyteller
you've got to tell people that used to
be bigger read every 240 uh-huh here you
what 6 7 6 4 6 4 6 4 6 7 is your
platform so yeah keep going I'm sorry
yes they'll be an edit so so you were so
when you open up your show being being
biographical being you know storytellers
you should talk about I used I went I
went to division three school mm-hmm you
know I used to forty blah blah blah and
then she'd come about I used to play
football at the Division three school
and do that a little bit I do that a
little bit about you know sixteen forty
women men all that stuff and then go
actually play football
I know it's hard look at this body now I
used to be 64 240
I never got in everybody talked about ol
king cause let's get judges I never ran
fast enough to get it and then you do
that for a bit right it's actually a big
it's good great it is such a good bit
and I've all I do about you tackling the
mic stand and your head is a neck as a
shock absorber it's brilliant and then
you turn around and then you're sort of
like humping you know that'll happen
this week that all evolved into it it's
really really good and then you do the
line in the and then when you have them
grab ya better go to shower right you
know yeah yeah and then you do like a
little pat on the butt good game you
know whatever whatever you do it's
really really good it sets a tone for
what your show is going to be okay it
sets a good tone and then once the crowd
is on your side once the crowd likes you
you can do everything about the accents
about Chinese about you all that so cuz
the crowd likes you they'd like you
they're not gonna unlike you once the
crowd likes you they're not gonna unlike
him it's true let's go once they like
you they're not gonna unlike you because
they go I like this guy Kirk wasn't so
good I like him I like him and that's
the key you know they're not gonna
unlike you it's very rare that you're
killing for 15 minutes in the crowd then
charge born you in touch to get off
stage it happens it's real rare okay
but once they like you they're gonna
always like you so be thinking of like
comics when they're thinking of their
opener it's like will one have an opener
that's like guaranteed laughs but also
the judge attempt that sets the tone for
their entire show and like what the
audience is in right I guess Mike a lot
of comics are told
save your best joke for last I complete
disagree hmm I can because if your best
joke is lastly to hear and you've been
sucking for 20 minutes then come down
right one of your best year that's why I
say abandon a kiss or prince or whoever
the big star is when they open the show
they open up with one of their biggest
hits kiss opens up with Detroit Rock
City or love God there being no Prince
opens up with let's go crazy
maybe his biggest hit me sets of 10 for
the evening comedians and I do the same
thing you can't you can't pull it your
best joke in reserve you've got to open
up within the first five minutes
you're one if not your best joke at
least one of your top three that you
know is gonna kill well you got going on
the Harmon gonna close the show if
you're both show is based on the one
closing [ __ ] you're not ready to be on
stage okay well I I mean my show
literally has five closures I got five
there are five different bits I have and
I can close my show literally I mean
I've got my I got my big finale which is
I suppose if I can close the show with
the motion a little bit I have I can
close the shoulder straitjacket bit I
had I can close the show with the
McGruff the Crime Dog I have
I can close the show with the bit that
had not done all week legit which is
this mind-reading bit by seeing when
doves cry these are all closed doors
open these are legitimate and this show
thought Neutron pop Claus closer between
none of them are but they're spaced out
throughout the show like it's like go to
firework show in the Pfizer yeah you
know so I don't save all my best jokes
the last five minutes and that's that's
you it doesn't make any sense to me so
need open up the show with one of them
with one of the big jokes in the show do
you find what I've noticed in telling
when we met last time and then you were
so generous to like in the office you
like let's have them back open for me
well we're here in August you know like
why why'd you immediately you're a good
writer
you're great writers like the rock see I
want and when I was talking to rich vols
feels like most comics talk from the
head and not from the heart so I'm
trying to insert the heart into it well
the autobiographical stuff like and kind
of combine that we're riding with like
the heart behind it though it's true but
rich Boston what good cause the base is
saying in that comment and I was trying
to get his head is again speak to what
you know right know what
who is Joel who is comic ex speak to
what you know speak from here if you
believe it
the audience will believe it if you do
enjoy if you do a joke about being
abducted by aliens anybody knows the
wrong
every joke
has to have a shred of believability
every joke no matter how outlandish it
is every joke has to have a shred of
believed a building as if it doesn't
know you're lying and they know that's
not real and that's to them is not funny
they want to believe it they want to
believe that you really tackled a guy
instead I'll see you in the showers did
it happen
no but could it have happened yeah it's
dad that's the cook that's what's funny
that's where the funny what didn't
happen
mm-hmm like I do a joke about no darling
of the fire department a rotary phone
I'm going 72 didn't 3 - did to death did
it really happen no could it have
happened yes and that's why it's so
funny are you really working comedian
and this and I'll clarify it because
this has come up more and more on the
podcast and I was just talking with
Robert Kelly about this great guy bit
like yes so nice and he he would roast
me a lot but that's endearment from him
yes but he um him and several other
comics have been harping more on like
you're not you're not trying to beat
Kevin Hart Kevin Hart is not he's not
the benchmark the benchmark is to create
a living doing what you love which is
comedy it's not trying to become like
the 1% of comedy it's like creating a
sustainable career around this crap and
you're someone yeah 26 years after I
discovered you and then this guy is
always booked consistently consistently
working like you're a successful
comedian yeah I think so
you know you young you are and it that
was a big mindset shift for me that's
like Oh Kevin Hart isn't the goal is to
make this like a like a livable job like
to make this we all can't be warm
don't copy a CEO yes and I think more
comedians need to understand that
mindset is like make this your job and
who could make period you can make this
accrual you can make a career out of
comedy
it takes determination it takes hustle
it takes ambition and it takes
perseverance probably perseverance is
should be maybe number one perseverance
because you will get rejected I've been
fired I was fired from a comedy club
called knuckleheads in Minneapolis
rich Miller Dennis Miller's brother
fired me thought I was horrible and it
was early my crew 1999 early my career
how many years into your career was that
six six years okay but I was still I
hadn't figured out exactly I it was
right after that firing that I create
the midnight swinger
because I knew that I there was
something wrong there was I was doing
something wrong but I used that as
motivation because I want to tell him a
few later and when I did I was able to
not at other epic I don't know everybody
but I was I was able to uh I was able to
see well you know reach a level where he
called me up he did not remember me at
all in being the power to say no is what
having the ability the word note is the
most powerful Wow so powerful so okay
again you can make a living a career a
good will out of doing comedy if you put
as much effort into it as if you would
if you were a young manager at a
corporation and you wanted to rip the
corporate ladder do you think yourself
okay I just graduate college
I've got a bachelor's degree company
hires me that's call company X to Lofton
the how you as apparently therefore
whatever alright
you then go to screw you get um if you
get your degree you pass the bar okay
we're gonna hire as a lawyer and okay
we're gonna give you these really
horrible cases you're just gonna get a
mentor he's good you can basically gonna
be writing briefs the next five years
you just writing briefs but you're
getting experience and these are okay
we're gonna give you a case we're gonna
give me an act engagement right right
look okay
now you're you're actually bringing in
client's you're actually gonna bring us
in clients now you making us money then
make you vice president we're gonna make
an executive we're gonna put your name
on the door you may never be the owner
of that wall for but you're now making a
living as a partner in that room think
it caught me the same way open my guest
sets grunt work biker bars outdoor music
festivals the horseshit caves a good
positive thing job if you do those for a
couple years but you're cutting your
teeth you're cutting the teeth and in
situations where you have to learn how
to think on your feet every crops
different it all sounds like someone
like me not trying to put my pet my cell
back you look someone like me I dig you
I want you to oak with me again I took a
little foot roll back on the show in
August and now you've booked this club
twice it's like okay now the clothes
know is you
and now you start working you know and
now people start root seeing your name
it's like okay I'm not headlining I'm
not a super storm a special event but
I'm featuring consistently all right you
do that for a couple years you stop
making connections because this business
is all about connections you stop main
engage with other comics comics like me
who had the power to say I want you on
the show I'm gonna bend roll with Nick
Joel's gonna open from anything the
clubs if they respect me and most them
do ago if you say Joel's good he's on
the show they would've been really nice
for tape you said Joel's good on the
show he's okay nice I think 19 featuring
and I also you go listen I'm gonna be
there Friday and Saturday but II need
you Wednesday through Sunday so you're
gonna headline Wednesday Thursday and
Sunday winter and also okay now you slip
me King now your head honey I'm gonna
say Thursday and Sunday and I came in on
Friday Sal you open for me and I'll said
okay they see a headline and now we're
talking 10 12 14 15 18 20 years within
that time you are moving up the ladder
and the whole time you are making this
living doing comedy mmm-hmm that's
perseverance that's ambition that's dry
that's what this is about
dude I knew I knew this was gonna be one
of our best episodes because just
because of the talk we had last time we
work together like this guy is oh well
of information and I can tell you care
about calm and you care about the
medians a deal but you just I don't feel
about all comedians you care about
helping the ones that when I see passion
you know will lie seep on fire yeah no I
see passion more than anything else I
don't need to see funniest find no funny
I know what someone can do I see what's
on stage what I look for is passion is
this what they want to do I know
somebody who's just doing this as a
part-time gig nothing what you spent for
nothing but respect well then I try gone
the road they're not trying to you know
create a show they're not looking to
travel the country they want to work
within in five six hours of where they
live that's that's who they are and I
respect that
that's that's the light they took and it
made us because you know they're married
they got kids that got in the game late
nothing wrong with it they have a type
of passion not what I'm looking for you
when I met you for the first time and we
had never met before you were actually a
cancellation feeling somebody who else
is yes I was yes and I don't know who
that I don't know who that comment was
who you filled in for someone cancer
Communion and they said we're gonna
bring baking I can't do it this guy
George could have come in and do it I
don't know who he is but it reminds me
of the story when the quarterback gets
injured in the backup water that comes
in because this guy you cancelled you
know may have been you may have been you
and I'd be talking to him right now
right but I saw your passion I saw you
on stage when this guy loves comedy I
could just see it I mean you and again
this is no disrespect
yeah if you don't take this because it's
been compliment no no you weren't
blowing the roof off the joint you
aren't getting standing ovations crowds
dug you and you are funny which is
important
but what I saw above everything else was
that you love being backstage you ain't
looking forward to hearing your name and
walking on said you had a smile on your
face when you walked on stage I've seen
every night this week to you up at 8:00
with a smile I see some college walk on
stage just looking pissed I like doing
you are living a dream you're on stage
at a well-respected Club in the country
you know and something some people will
call this club when the top 10 clubs in
the country throughout for 30 years
Blues are packed this is a this is a
club that's you see if you see the
comedy catch in Chattanooga people go I
gotta get into that booth I got it cut
who do you know you know I mean I had I
had a comedian messaged me on IG going
oh by the way IG is in Graham at a mr.
show Todd Davis got these follow me oh
yeah who said oh my god I've heard
nothing but amazing things about this
club can you get me in
maybe I don't know right if I think your
style but my point being is that you
know you should be walking you want to
save her to smile and you're happy you
delivered every joke like he meant it
and I'm like going like that guy that
guy's got that guy's got passion so I
took you aside I copped yeah and then
after the show on Sunday we're talking
to Danielle in the green in the green
room I've came back as I say put him on
the show in Daniels like be sure I'm
like absolutely put him on the show
right there so you know you got booked
like seven months you get a [ __ ]
seven month cells so cool yeah but again
and I and I would vouch for you again
any club that asked me about you I'm
gonna say yeah did a strong future put
them on put them on so I think it's just
a it's a compliment to you because I see
your passion I see your love for the
business and you can do comedy right you
can treat calm you like karaoke if you
want to nothing wrong with that you can
go out to the open mic night and kill it
for three minutes
just like someone goes to karaoke and
kills tiny dancer viola jaw then never
got a record that's all they're never
gonna be a professional singer they're
not gonna tour right but for three
minutes they killed tiny dancer and they
feel good about themselves if that's
what you want to call me god bless you
good luck to you thank you for thank you
for having fun doing this we leave
people like you in this industry
somebody goes to karaoke and destroys
and goes I'm gonna record that song I'm
gonna put that song than you two
do my version and such promoting
themselves that's passionate so and you
doing what you do especially at this hot
breath podcast is when we start talking
on this thing was just very tiny was
very little mm-hmm and were there seven
months it has blown up you got Cedric
the Entertainer on this show yeah I mean
it shows that passion passion and now
but you submit no one's ever done your
show before you go the calm during a
podcast it's good there's nothing less
sexy than eating and there's no way to
like halfway eat it's like it all your
mouth yeah it's your entire it's cut
it's kind of like you know going on a
hot-air balloon ride you know
it's sounds romantic until you realize
that you're not alone
there's some guy let's let you enjoy no
no we keep on talking I was just
thinking of a it's kind of cool kind of
closing or any other advice you have for
comics I know you're full of information
it's like is there anything that you
have found to be most helpful that
you've learned or any closing advice you
can share for comics well the standard
device
hmm I use a lot and it's boilerplate
advice before gonna take a drink before
the time of course I'm eating chicken as
we this is now the food cast of it as
I'm why'd you flip out if we go we do a
quick wipe we got it
I love how people know the show that are
on the show that's a standard
boilerplate response to young communists
keep on writing always keep writing
always keep writing always keep blogging
read out a lot and I'm like that's the
advice you give us somebody here you
should really don't want to give advice
to it's kinda like I you go get them
it's it's like it's like it's like when
you're playing football you know you're
gonna get your ass huh you know but your
dad goes have a good game you know
you're gonna lose by a tease it's like
what Alabama plays some division to zone
and the codes I go okay guys this is
Alabama the number one team for the past
decade well I don't have to say anything
else except have a good game guys it's
gonna be a long hour
and at Alabama always dismiss for the
first point and then the underscore like
116 is 7 sure so so what I would tell
young comics and I love work with young
comics I've worked with I love helping
out young comments it says when I see
passion well I about lyric a hope help
you with some bits and some jokes is
timing I would say more than anything
else nothing is better than stage time
there is nothing there is nothing that
you can do more to advance your career
than stage time and I mean any stage
time if you believe that you can only
improve as a community by doing shows at
comedy clubs you are not gonna make it
in this business so you've gotta find
places to do show even if that means I
know I've said to some people you that
means putting on a show at a friend's
barbecue you know there's gonna be 50
people on stage time will make you a
better community in that it more than
any one other thing you could do you can
write your ass off you can write the
best jokes ever if you're not talking on
a stage it's wasted what's the point so
if there is an open mic not a comedy
open mic understanding an open mic I was
1992 in Britain is a great story night
93 I'm living in LA place called the
Inland Empire Rancho Cucamonga
California I got I got I got you got
married the courthouse in Rancho
Cucamonga surprised at what but this is
1993 I had just graduated from college
23 years old I moved from Columbia
Missouri way after school so like on the
way out to like a fade away okay so it's
1992 Illinois
I said state time is important to the
famous guy my publicist told me where to
pay so it's not just 1993 and I'm
basically been in the business for I
started doing comedy when I was 16 years
old in 86 oh my god yeah catch you
rising star was the first place every
day my foot would I did my first show in
New York st. Louis oh my so this calls
you Union Station my dad was a Broadway
performer I've been from for boys that
was five years old so I've been
performing since I was five but I was my
dad plumbed on Broadway off-broadway I
was raised in the theatre community
anyway first time I did stand-up I was
eight 16 years old and then all
throughout you know high school I was in
the theater department in Kyle
but I always wanted to be a stand-up
comedian actually wrote a paper when I
was 13 years old that said what do you
wanna be when you grow up and I wrote I
want to be a stand-up comedian my mom
still actually has the paper and yeah
there's this I I wanted to do since I
was 13 years old when I saw Steve Martin
live the universal Amphitheatre I said
you can make a living playing a banjo
looking for work we ahead how do I do
that
where did you see him you saw him live
no and I saw him on HBO okay yeah he
already he'd already tied from doing
stand about that but he's no my
favorites thread loved him so I'm just
trying to get in in LA is tough Elia
stuff and in 93 it was a comedy was kind
of on the decline
we had the highs of the 80s and now in
the 90s and shows like evening at the
improv Caroline's comedy central people
now watch you stand up on TV and the
comedy club scene was dropping down so
it was hard to get work there was a time
and you can literally just open up a bar
to take a banner outside said comedy
night and the place to be patented there
was a time not anymore preferring to be
a time there goes the golden years in
the eighties so 93 I'm just trying to
get into stage I'm trying to I'm working
as a house and see that place called the
last stop but I instantly know and la
O&L if they were actually - laughs -
okay laughs after Houston last up in LA
actually it was actually up in
California they were connected they were
both owned by the same guy so I'm
working there as a house them see but
I'm not I'm as I'm seeing on my off
knives I really want to work on me
mature as an MC you got you got a very
limited base on what you can do Allison
for stage time I'm working at stage time
it was four o'clock
in Rancho Cucamonga on a Sunday at a
coffeehouse the coffeehouse
went full packed every seat taken 13
people open mic night open mic day was
opened my day was for anybody you show
up and you get five minutes I won stage
time I want to work on jokes I walk in
there it's basically a roomful of
California hippies saying the worst
poetry I've ever heard I know is this
cliche one guy was [ __ ] playing
behind at bongos I swear to God the smog
smog get rid of the smog and I'm like
going and in my mind thinking I've got
to follow that that's one thing is I'd
call the crowd really dead the corrode
so I was actually doing a Sunday at 4
o'clock in front with 13 people
basically 23 year old tiny dick jokes
and the thing is comedy is a lot like
golf all you you could play 18 holes of
golf suck but you have one good shot and
you remember that jobs like I'm coming
back
no harmony you can suck five maybe you
get one and a half yep you're like yes
that's exactly it
so that so - everybody out that I know
you do a comedy class which i think is
brilliant I'm glad that someone's
actually trying to help with young
comedians have how to write how to start
I didn't get my water bottle but yeah
it's a hot it's a hot it's a souvenir
I'm glad that you are getting people to
do and I've watched some of the clips on
the IG story I'm glad you're doing that
and I don't know what actually goes on
in the closet it's just straight up
writing performing but yeah it's long if
you are you get but I would suggest is
make sure they feel like they're
fulfilling set up the room so it feels
like a nightclub because if you just
performing in a bank it up in a
conference room with the windows open if
you're walking by you don't feel the the
realness of what's like to actually be
on stage so I would actually kill the
lights close the curtains make make
people sit like you're at us in a
comment at a drama club get them they go
this is what its gonna guide people
gonna be looking at you then I don't
want cocktail Venus you know
kill the lights maybe get a good mic
stand a microphone that's working with
the PAS and a stool you know have
somebody go as a John Cleese walking us
can mean it having a true emcee bring
them onstage you know get them to feel
like this and indigo and I've been
saying this forever
never bring notes on stage yes leave if
they cannot memorize five minutes you're
not rated on stage leave the notebook at
home leave it at that you can bring it
to the club but don't bring on stage
with you yeah nothing shows you as
lesser a professional when you go anyway
so oh yeah
so in my sister one who gets away that
was Richard Lewis because what you Lewis
made a joke you know
but looking at no just makes you
honestly go this isn't real there's
nothing real about this is fake I've
never seen a comic with notes on stage
succeed ever ever and none of the pros
do it so when you do those classes I
again that's brilliant
so gladsome is doing it and you need
your performance but make it feel like
it's a performance yes because I saw you
once I go on okay
Jim's going up okay go Jim right no move
the move the table all the way of course
I'd actually get rid of tables I that
conference table I don't think you learn
in the conference tables just sit down
no fan go just talk back and forth I
always collect tables a way to separate
people anyway so I know just get the
tape look at the chairs set it up you
know almost have you teach the class
from where the stage is and you're
talking to the people from the stage you
know so they feel like this is a mistic
comedy venue this I feel a second exit
brilliant this build a comedy venue and
then they will get the sense like okay
I'm gonna go on stage and tell jokes and
nothing is higher than telling jokes in
front of people you know at other comics
there's other comics and not laughs or
the comics cuz I go
in don't think that I think he's funnier
than me and now they won't book me you
know I will laugh harder at another
comic if I think they're funny because
I've got confidence in myself if you
have confidence in yourself you've got
no worries my mentor Kirk Noland back in
95 gave me pride the best advice I've
ever gotten in comedy and I'm the shirt
Sheriff exclusive because this is going
to come off as arrogant it's gonna come
off as condescending it's gonna come off
as elitist but when you hear what I'm
saying in its pure form you'll get it
when you're a comedian whether you're
the MC the guest set the feature or the
headliner when you walk into that room
in your head not out loud in your head
you repeat I'm the funniest [ __ ]
here doesn't matter the emcee you're not
a guest set feature the headliner in
your head you go I'm the funniest
[ __ ] here and if you think that
you'll stop believing in
and then you will be the headline this
special event because there's nobody in
your mind who's funnier than you in that
entire room I've done shows with some of
the grace for some of the Grace and
before every show to this day I'm in the
green room and I walk up to you I have a
good show mm-hmm you want to say my head
I said that's not what I said that's not
what I said that's that's that's mistake
yeah that's the mistake I know you make
it no make a joke on I'm being serious
about this it's not about des meeting
you now back to me near the kayaks it's
about lifting yourself up okay to make
you believe because if you don't believe
that you're the funniest person in the
room guess what you're not the funniest
person in the room 26 years that's the
best advice that's incredible how you
can boil it down to 16 shows now yeah
every time I walk is Dave what do I look
like when I walk on stage he's
undefeated
yeah it's you're undefeated seriously
I'm watching you work every time it's
just a consistent like you bring it
every single time
yeah I know what I say for every show
I'm the funniest [ __ ] here
that's right
sure every every comic every kind of
while talking to Kelly
every comic every comment every comic
should do it again it's not kind of
sending you're not saying it to the
meeting I say to anybody else right I'm
not walk up to you go hey Joel
I'm gonna find his [ __ ] here
have a good set mm-hmm that what I'm
doing it's not what I'm doing
it's in your head you can't lift
yourself up
then you're shooting for the long night
well I tell you what man this what I
love about the hot breath reverse is
that they reach out to guests and they
thank them where they say you said this
or that and I encourage almost more than
any other episode please do this but let
them know where they can connect with
you yeah just like thank you say you how
my help will you work oh I love talking
to comics I love helping off I can but
if you want to contact with me Instagram
at I am is just Showtime David Scott
Facebook but that's for the older comics
out there over the age of 40 cat I am at
your Showtime and my website very simple
damn I look good calm no that's really
that website that's really my website
yeah I got that website for 15 years
I've actually had torn sides want to buy
that side off me I swear to god you
wouldn't sell it no why would I
it's a it's the most unique website name
in the world sure probably people I
think people say this oh damn I look
good what that website exists was that I
could I get like them I get like a hit
from from like um like Uruguay it's like
oh it's someone you know types in right
types in like I would I would do it if I
can have that who's this midnight swing
mister Showtime what made you get that
he's like yeah you can I catch place
really yeah
for has to swinger show the next player
didn't I swinger Oh Mike you can search
because what a name you can search it
the midnight swinger it was all about
ego and attitude Vegas and the whole
show was about me saying damn good I had
a mirror on stage I did a picture myself
take a photograph myself on stage it was
a great bit
I had this is back when they were
disposable cameras uh-huh or cell phones
I have five of them on ID for my body
and I hid one in the audience and I
would just I was just during the show
yeah I just stopped I would tell a joke
and go damn I look good take a camera
and then throw the camera side no no
five six minutes go by I'll do a joke I
go damn I look good
take another camera take a picture I do
that four times and then during my
closing musical bits I'd be in the
audience singing Sweet Caroline and
there was a part of music where that
really would just stop you just stop I
go I look good I reach under a table
grab another camera and take a picture
and the girl and the crowds like cameras
this guy that's incredible
and now you stripped like literally ten
layers like you have to put on that many
layers it's that it's actually I
actually did a video it's actually on
Instagram it's a sped up video of me
putting how many layers I wear if you
include the underwear and socks it's
nine layers nine layers every show every
shop and its undefeated Joe is under my
friend Willie Farrell who tell me you
may have heard of not the after the
comedian hmm out of Des Moines called
the guy he's the Godfather of comedy
search out really felt he's brilliant
Wow brilliant his entire shows almost
all improv it's brilliant show love
we've been good friends for 15 16 years
I was in Des Moines recently and he did
not tell me was coming to show his ball
his wife and they came to my show and my
buddy Dwayne Clark who's my my Midwest
opener him at girlfriends and I'm on
stage and Willy is talking to Duane he's
like going this is Duane tell me the
story later he goes really walk did you
do I didn't want you you were there do
you want to make you nervous and I came
in after you started he walks in goes
finally Showtime has put on some weight
it's about time and it looks like he
goes no I don't think that that is comic
in Des Moines and then the show goes on
and then he goes he goes then every 10
minutes you take off Italy of closing go
do that makes me think about Craig
shoemaker the love-master
yeah his is like bravado and like like
you're saying the midnight swinger was
that character and he was on air he said
like the craziest groupie story we've
ever heard on here oh look the there was
there's a lot involved it was him being
the love-master imagine I've got the
midnight swingers oh I bet you had some
people after the show we were like hey I
think and not to get not to get killed a
buzz but no and only because I treed
this is my treaters of the business
I I bought you treat this as a business
I don't put up that vibe I know there
are some comics you prop the vibe like
going hey we're gonna get high after
sure it doesn't stop a looking hook-up I
know some comics do it and they're
single and this fine that's wrong with
it hey we're all adults this is show
business
show business take care of your business
and treat it like it is if you want to
have a successful business treat it like
a successful business you want to use as
a hobby do whatever all you want to do I
know that's not I know we kind of joking
around but that's it's been a great to
you yeah if you have the show any of the
business you've got to be fully balanced
both I so mindset again - can both that
mindset right the business that if this
is the business of drawbars the business
of Eric Louis this is the business of
mr. Showtime this is your this is your
company you know granted the Christmas
party's gonna be very boring because
it's just you and thank you so much for
doing this man oh yeah it was gonna be
gold but the last thing comics always do
is they just look into the camera and
let me know let people know why they
should listen to hot brass I think the
best was a hot rod this guy right here
this man really cares about comedy
really cares about stand-up and I will
not be on the show by not see passion
this guy so if you want to learn about
calm you want to learn about and we're
talking on all levels of comedy from the
mega stars like such an entertainer so
someone like me who's just a lowly
Guinness world record holder the only
one that's only one the comedy world you
can say it how many hours 40 hours and
eight minutes forty hours in it yeah I'm
not saying that's not the greatest
achievement in comedy history that's not
for me to say I'm gonna let the
historians decide what's more important
part of the city or longer stand-up
comedy show ever I'm gonna you all the
sides
I was so inside comedy is like Kevin's
gonna be mad at me that's okay we're
about the same height I can dunk on
Kevin although he does know the rock so
I'm probably he's gonna jumanji me so
listen listen to this guy he cares about
comedy he cares about what you need to
make it in this business so hot breath I
hope that I'll see you all again on the
road soon will we'll definitely be doing
another one absolute we're gonna be
doing more of these for sure so we'll
get into the world record and all that
on the next one but this one I just
wanted to be raw comedy talk in a way
this show hasn't really done in terms of
just like here in the middle of a meal
just like this is the truth about
comments not promoting nothing
thank you for sharing oh man thank you
all right Oh Eric great job we had a
live podcast today great job Eric sorry
hot breath of ours get with it let me
let them know where they can keep you up
with you - Eric I'm on Facebook as well
it's Eric lowness damn close comedian
just check me out I do have a youtube
it's called Eric low nose just check it
out
it's Alawis mes that's how you all right
well comedians reach out to mr. Showtime
reach out to Eric if you just want to
feel good about yourself and your comedy
career very long
reach out to mr. Showtime let them know
how helpful this was on what you enjoyed
about it and share this with other
comics and we'll be back next Monday
right here on hot breath okay
you both did at the same time
[Music]